dans les rues d'antacia dans le sud de
la Turquie Bilal montre fièrement des
photos de ses filles c'est pour elle
qu'il quittent à regret la maison où
elles sont nées
la maison tient plus d'eau ni
d'électricité dit-il on part vivre chez
mon oncle à 200 km d'ici c'est mieux
pour les enfants et pour le travail
un opticien qui possédait deux boutiques
et un café a décidé de rester coûte que
coûte
aussi loin que je me souvienne j'ai vécu
ici dit-il je veux rester ici pour le
reste de ma vie alors que les recherches
de survivants sont arrêtées sauf dans
deux provinces de Turquie tous les
efforts convergent maintenant vers la
survie de millions de sinistrés et de
déplacer les loger et les nourrir relève
de l'exploit alors que l'aide
humanitaire arrive au compte-goutte
particulièrement dans le nord de la
Syrie
de petites entreprises locales ont donc
entrepris de fabriquer des tentes pour
offrir un toit temporaire au millier de
personnes qui ont tout perdu mais dans
un pays qui manque de tout les matières
premières sont difficiles à trouver
on fabrique 25 à 50 ans par jour 17
hommes mais on manque de matériaux pour
en faire plus en particulier de l'acier
l'aide d'international est cruciale pour
faire face aux immenses besoins le
secrétaire d'État américain Anthony
blinken arrivé ce matin en Turquie a
d'ailleurs promis 100 millions de
dollars supplémentaires pour aider les
sinistrés Washington avait déjà fourni
du matériel médical et de l'équipement
pour les recherches ainsi qu'un fond
d'aide de 85 millions de dollars
et alors qu'on ignore encore le nombre
exact de morts et de disparu sous les
décombres des bénévoles entreprises
d'accrocher des ballons rouges aux
ruines pour symboliser toutes ces vies
innocents perdus quand la terre a
tremblée il y a 14 jours ici lise
Villeneuve Radio-Canada Montréal